Ju: It's the cinematic
event of the decade,
and this is 31 details
that you might have missed
in "Avengers: Endgame."
Now, first up, we won't
be revealing what happens
in the end, who wins or loses,
if anyone dies, or what
the plot of the film is.
Instead, we will be
focusing on Easter eggs,
details, things you might have missed,
and what the possible tie-ins are
to Marvel's upcoming TV series on Disney+.
But we will be issuing a spoiler alert
because it reveals details
that happen in the film.
Right, strap in because we
have a lot to get through.
First up, fans had hoped that the classic
Marvel post-credits will
contain some callback
to the shawarma scene in
the first "Avengers" movie
or something that links to
"Fantastic Four" or "X-Men"
as Disney purchased 20th Century Fox
and will retain the rights
to some of the characters.
But there are no post-credit
scenes in "Endgame."
Instead we're treated to
the Marvel hammer logo
with a single loud "clink" sound.
This might be a direct callback
to the sound Iron Man makes
when he first casts his helmet
all the way back in 2008's "Iron Man."
This would be a fitting tribute
to the hammer strike that
sparked 22 movies over 11 years.
Or is it actually the sound of a bell
to toll all the characters
that have been lost?
Have a listen for yourself.
Having worked as executive
producers on "Community,"
the Russo brothers are no strangers
to having actors from the
series pop up in their films.
Look out for Yvette Nicole Brown
in a lift with a security badge
and Ken Jeong as a guard of a lockup.
Jeong is also reading the
book "Terminal Breach,"
which has some parallels to the mass loss
of life in "Infinity War."
The Russo brothers love to slip
in TV and movie references.
"Endgame" is no different.
A scene where Hawkeye runs from enemies,
as shown from the trailers, appears
to be a direct shout-out
to the tunnel scene in "Aliens."
Also look out for
shout-outs to "Die Hard,"
"Hot Tub Time Machine,"
and "The Big Lebowski."
Listen out to a reference for
cheeseburgers in the movie.
It's a reference to the "Iron Man" scene
where Tony Stark returns from captivity
only to immediately demand a cheeseburger.
It's a fun nod to actual events
in Robert Downey Jr.'s life.
He claims the horror of
eating a Burger King meal
whilst on a drug-fueled
drive snapped him out
of his addiction and set
him on a cleaner path.
From the trailer, we know that Hawkeye
is mentoring his daughter at archery.
Almost in passing, he
refers to her as Hawkeye.
This will delight fans
of the female Hawkeye,
Kate Bishop, in the comics.
Will we be seeing a female Hawkeye?
Later in the movie, Hawkeye's involved
in a street fight. You might
recognize the actor he's
up against as Japanese
movie star Hiroyuki Sanada.
Right, thanks to the Disney+ announcement,
we know of several
post-"Endgame" spinoffs.
One of these is with
Falcon and Winter Soldier.
In the movie, Anthony Mackie's character,
Sam Wilson, inherits Cap's shield.
We know from the comics
Sam becomes Captain America
and that there have been
multiple Caps over the years.
So is it possible that he might appear
in this role in the upcoming series?
Speaking of Disney+, we know
that a Loki series is in the works,
as is one with Scarlet Witch and Vision,
although it's unclear
as to whether these will
be prequels or follow
the events of "Endgame."
Scarlet Witch certainly
gets her screen time
in "Endgame" and reminds us
of how powerful she really is,
deserving of the solo series.
Stan Lee's cameo is as good as we hoped.
In the '70s, he's driving a car
while shouting, "Make love, not war!"
Both the number plate on the car
and what he's saying
have significance here.
Liberal-minded Lee was
assigned to the Army
aged 19 in World War II but
used his comic-book platform
later in life to comment
on the Vietnam War,
student protests, and political activism.
In the film, we get to see
Pepper Potts in the RESCUE suit.
Now, in the comics, Tony
builds this suit for Pepper.
A photo of this was leaked last year,
so fans were expecting
Potts to be battle-ready.
At one point in the movie,
an all-female lineup
including Pepper Potts, Nebula,
and Okoye take on enemies.
This is a direct reference to the series
"A-Force" with a lineup of
She-Hulk, Dazzler, and Medusa.
It might be a heavy-handed
feminist moment,
but it certainly reminds us all
of the female heroes in the MCU.
The number A113 makes an
appearance yet again in this movie.
Disney fans will be
familiar with this number
from nearly every single Pixar movie.
It refers to a classroom number
at the California Institute of the Arts.
Speaking of numbers,
whilst leaving a message
for Pepper in space at the film's start,
Tony says that it's been
21, no, make it 22 days
that they've been lost in space.
"Endgame" is the 22nd movie in the MCU.
And numbers again, when Thanos
has gone to planet 0259-S,
the Avengers try to find him.
The number 259 might refer to "Avengers"
volume 1, edition 259, which heavily
features Captain America and Nebula.
In a pivotal scene in the movie,
Black Widow has a callback line
to Budapest from "Avengers."
Black Widow: It's like
Budapest all over again.
Hawkeye: You and I remember
Budapest very differently.
Ju: Budapest is a thread
that goes all the way
through the MCU, with Edwin
Jarvis meeting Anna there.
Even Nick Fury's backstory
has him retrieving CIA
information there with Escobar.
And in the "Iron Man 2" video game,
Pepper Potts even makes a visit there.
Codirector Joe Russo has a cameo
in the group-therapy scene in the film.
Joe has had cameos in all
of the "Avengers" movies
he's directed, even appearing
dead in a tub in "Civil War,"
so look out for that.
"Hail Hydra!" This phrase is uttered
by Captain America at one point.
It's a shout-out to
the controversial comic
"Captain America: Steve Rogers 1,"
where Cap has a darker story arc,
which fans have got hyped over.
In a laboratory scene, we
also hear Toby Jones' voice
off-screen as the evil Arnim Zola.
It's here that we get a glimpse
of the original "Ant-Man" comic helmet
lying on a table whilst being
attended to by Hank Pym.
Loads of Marvel movies show
a character losing an arm.
Now, this is actually a reference
to the Luke Skywalker
hand-chop in "Star Wars."
In this film, Nebula
corrupts her metal frame
when she half-burns off her hand.
Near the end of the movie, keep a lookout
for Ty Simpkins from "Iron Man 3."
He's the kid Tony is
stranded with in Rose Hill
who snaps him out of his anxiety attack,
and he makes a brief cameo in "Endgame."
INSIDER confirmed this.
Also, look out for the gift
that Pepper gives Tony Stark
in "Iron Man," proof that
Tony Stark has a heart.
It was used when Tony
collapses in his home
and needs a quick fix to
his core being compromised.
Watch out for the name "Morgan."
In "Infinity War," Tony says Morgan
is the name of an eccentric
uncle that Pepper had.
In the comics, it's a
name of a cousin Tony has,
who schemes against him to try
and take control of Stark Industries.
It's the name of an important
character in "Endgame."
In the "Iron Man" movies,
we repeatedly see Tony Stark
on a Rolling Stone cover that says,
"Tony Stark wants to save the world."
It's a nice full-circle moment then
that he contributes towards
doing that in "Endgame."
Viewers might feel a little déjà vu
when listening out for some
of the MCU's most quotable lines.
The "Captain America" line,
"Don't do anything stupid
until I get back." "How can I?
You're taking all the stupid
with you," makes a return, as does,
"I could do this all day."
There are also some location-specific
lines to look out for.
Cap revisits his
conversation with Spider-Man
in "Civil War" saying,
"Hey, Queens, what's up?"
In the earlier movie, Cap had told Peter
that he was from Brooklyn.
Also, Tony refers to Doctor Strange
as "The Bleecker Street Magician."
Strange's Sanctum Sanctorum was
on Bleecker Street in NYC,
and they use Bleecker Street
as a nickname for him twice.
We also get a mention of
Black Widow's dad's name.
This character's past has
been shrouded in secrecy,
but revealing the name
of her parents could lead
to a more fleshed-out backstory
when her solo movie arrives.
One of the final scenes
of the film alludes
to Captain America's ability
to wield other weapons.
There's a callback to the
moment in "Age of Ultron"
where Cap just manages to
lift Thor's hammer, Mjolnir.
It's a Steve Rogers we're familiar with
from "The Mighty Thor" and "Fear Itself,"
and it proves a real treat for fans.
We fittingly end on
Captain America's backside,
which fans went wild over
in the "Endgame" posters.
The Russo brothers are known
for fitting memes and jokes
into their movies, so the joke
about Captain America's butt
being "America's a--" will
be a delight to some fans.
Of course, there are tons more references
that we could've put into this list,
but these are some of our favorites.
Think we've missed
anything? Comment below.
We fittingly end on Captain
America's backside, which...
[Laughs] Talking about someone's bum.